- Joining us now,
another brilliant, beautiful
and talented woman.
She's a mama of three with
her husband, Stephen Curry.
And she has a new cookbook out right now.
It's called "The Full Plate".
You should buy it, if you like food.
Let's dial in Ayesha Curry y'all.
(mellow music)
Oh my gosh.
- It's smooth.
Hi.
- I mean.
- You are perhaps,
you get this all the time,
but just take the compliment.
You are perhaps
one of the most beautiful woman
I've ever seen on the planet.
- That's very sweet.
Stop it,
Thank you guys.
- I mean, even in that dress.
- Oh my gosh.
Like God did,
- Very sweet.
he had a good day with you, Ma'am.
Okay, so Ayesha, how is your mommy?
I know, you have wine, yes.
- [Ayesha] I have wine.
- (laughing) So how is
your mommy pandemic going?
Is remote learning the
worst for you as well?
- It's going, right.
Like it's going.
But luckily for me,
Stephen has really stepped in
with the education and their schooling.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And I'm okay with that.
Because I said, you know, I birth them.
So now you can birth and
nurture their education.
- [Kelly] I get it.
- [Ayesha] So,
- And he's actually doing it?
- He's doing it.
Yeah, I'm so grateful.
But it's, you know,
he's making up for lost
time to be quite frank.
Because he would sleep through
all of the diaper changes
and the late nights when they were babies.
And so now this is his strong suit.
- Well, it's all about being a good team.
So that's awesome.
Well, you have an awesome new cookbook
called "The Full Plate".
And what can we expect to find in it?
It looks delicious what you're eating.
- [Ayesha] Oh my gosh.
- Yes.
- I'm so excited about this cookbook.
And it will be four years almost
to the day since the first book came out.
And with this book,
you know, life was really chaotic
and I wanted the book to reflect that.
And so it's filled with
quick, easy recipes
that don't lack flavor.
'Cause I've always found
that a lot of them that are quick
lack that umami and that deliciousness.
So there's 15, 20, 30 minute recipes,
nothing ever over an hour.
And I think the best
part about the book is
there's a huge cocktails chapter.
And I highly encourage people
- Awesome.
to make a cocktail first,
so that they can drink
while making the meal.
- Yeah, that's the only
time you'll find me cooking
is if there is a glass of wine involved.
- [Ayesha] Has to be.
- Do your kids like cooking?
Have you gotten them into it?
- They do.
They love helping me
as much as I let them.
So we often cook together.
And I've lucked out with them
because they're super adventurous eaters.
So that's always been nice.
But I think it's because they cook with me
and have a hand in making
the meals occasionally.
- Um.
- That's why they're interested
in trying new things.
- Yeah, my daughter's always,
every time we're in the kitchen together,
she always wants to use the knife
and I'm like it's a little weird
how much you wanna use the knife.
It's actually a little.
- [Woman] Right.
- So are your kids into cooking?
Do they like it?
- Mine are more into it
if I was more into it.
Look, we have strengths and weaknesses
and mine is not in the kitchen.
I'm gonna buy your book.
- Mine is not either.
- [Kelly] I'm gonna buy the book.
- Mine aren't into cooking
or eating actually.
So yeah,
- What?
it's very upsetting to see
that you're so beautiful
and you have adventurous
eaters as children.
That's, like, it's ruined my day.
- Oh my God, my boy
doesn't eat really at all.
But my girl, well, she's
like, I'll eat anything.
As long as there's some
kind of treat coming.
She's like, I will eat
anything in the world.
Yeah, she's kind of like that.
So what, you also launched
a magazine, "Sweet July".
So what.
- Good job.
I know, that's amazing.
Like who launches magazines?
It's like, what was your
inspiration for that?
- I don't know.
I'm still trying to
figure out like how they,
they chose me to do this.
But I'm so thrilled about it.
I, you know, it's called "Sweet July"
because all of the kids were born in July
and it's one of the
happiest times in our life.
And one of the most exciting,
and I was like why can't we implement
the way that we feel today
into our everyday life?
So the magazine's
- Oh.
really a mantra to just,
you know, keep it positive,
keep it fresh and
exciting every single day.
And there are little ways
that you can do that along the way.
So it's celebrating the small moments
along with the big things.
And so that's how "Sweet July" came about.
And it's just this reflection
of diversity and inclusivity.
And I'm just excited about it.
The second issue comes out
next month and I can't wait.
- Oh my God,
(audience applaud)
that's incredible.
I feel like you're doing so many things.
So, Ayesha's book y'all,
it's called "The Full Plate"
and it's available now.
And I literally want
whatever you're eating
on the cover of it.
It looks amazing.
And look up.
- Crab Bucatini.
Is that what it is?
- Yes, it is so good.
- Oh my God, I would eat that.
I will, I would, if you made it,
it looks like you're awesome.
So I would eat anything you made.
But, and everybody look
out for "Sweet July"
at your local newsstand.
I love how you came up
with the name of your magazine as well.
That is so beautiful.